lange wurde diskutiert jetzt wird sie
kommen die impfpflicht der künftige
kanzler will sie nämlich das hat olaf
scholz hierbei bild exklusiv angekündigt
hat sie der wind ganz schön gedreht in
den letzten wochen von total gegen die
impfpflicht zu total für die empfiehlt
impfpflicht häufig gefallen wird im
pflicht ist in deutschland nicht möglich
und weil es ja schon wieder anders
behauptet wird auch in den sozialen
medien ich gebe ihnen mein wort ich gebe
ihnen mein wort es wird in dieser
pandemie keine infos geben hören sie
endlich auf anderes zu bauen pflicht
halte ich für falsch und im pflicht ist
in deutschland nicht möglich
tja was schert mich mein geschwätz von
gestern könnte man sagen jetzt klingt
das so bei olaf scholz
da wo menschen ganz besonders geschützt
werden müssen den
altenpflegeeinrichtungen krankenhäuser
müssen die beschäftigten sich impfen
lassen und gleichzeitig brauchen wir für
einen zeitpunkt im nächsten jahr das
kann anfang februar das kann anfang märz
sein die aussage bis dahin sollten sich
aber alle geimpft haben denn meine idee
mein vorschlag ist ja dass der zeitpunkt
bis zu dem dann jeder und jede sich habt
impfen lassen auch nicht allzu fern
liegt also mein vorschlag anfang februar
oder anfang märz
zack dann soll sie kommen die
impfpflicht hat sich bei ihnen zu hause
auch der wind gedreht von gegen die
impfpflicht bis für die impfpflicht wir
haben den bild check gemacht heute ich
bin für die impfpflicht weil ich finde
dass es
normal ist dass wir zu solchen zeiten
alle als gemeinschaft zusammenhalten was
jetzt die politik macht ihr mit die
impfpflicht was er einführen wollen bin
ich nicht direkt einverstanden ist soll
jedoch über sein eigenes leben ich bin
gegen eine gesetzliche pflicht weil
zwänge sind niemals gut ich bin gegen
eine gesetzliche pflicht leichter
meinung wenn jeder sollte über seinen
körper selber verfügen und das mit sich
selber abmachen ich bin generell gegen
alles was pflicht ist also man kann auch
die kühe nehmen und man kann es
vielleicht auch so sagen dass man darum
bittet jetzt im moment bei der aktuellen
situation aber mit gewalt hat noch nie
etwas geklappt ich bin gegen eine
impfpflicht weil ich finde dass freiheit
das wichtigste ist also ich befürworte
die pflicht also nicht unbedingt weil
sie keinen hundertprozentigen schutz
bietet und weil es nicht meiner ansicht
nach dem nach den langfristigen
auswirkungen noch nicht erforscht sind
ich bin aber dann dafür dass man
konsequent ist denn dann auch keinen
klinik platz in anspruch nimmt wenn man
dann tatsächlich
angesicht ansteckt ich bin gegen die
impfpflicht das soll jeder halten wie er
will und jeder so ist ein eigenes risiko
haben oder nicht ich bin auch eigentlich
schon aus solidaritäts gründen dafür
dass man dann wieder ein halbwegs
vernünftiges leben schön kann für eine
impfpflicht war will keine toten mehr
haben das ist für mich der wichtigste
grund zu sagen impfpflicht ja auf jeden
fall und wenn jemand gegen die
impfpflicht ist denn würde ich echt dazu
verdonnern mal auf so eine
intensivstation zu gehen und dort mal zu
schauen wie es dort aussieht und wie es
keine pflegekräfte geht ich glaube damit
ist eigentlich alles gesagt was für eine
impfpflicht spricht
auch die meinungen weit auseinander und
auch bei uns hier bei beltz offen wir
uns über die impfpflicht der streit geht
mitten durch unsere redaktion
[Musik]
das duell um die impfpflicht hier bei
uns bei bild zweimal bild zweimal frau
vier mal geimpft mittlerweile und zwei
völlig unterschiedliche meinungen zur
impfpflicht nina schenk ist total gegen
die impfpflicht yvonne weiß total dafür
ring frei für euch bei
[Musik]
er über ein für mich persönlich ist es
schwierig dass es überhaupt menschen
gibt die für die impfpflicht sind ich
finde es ganz ganz schlimm vor allem
wenn man auch die politiker an schaut
sie haben uns den ganzen sommer
versprochen angela merkel auch olaf
scholz christian linder die impfpflicht
wird es nicht geben angela merkel hat
übrigens auch ein argument gebracht im
sommer weil sich heute noch für richtig
finde angela merkel hat gesagt man würde
vertrauen verspielen wenn man die
impfpflicht einführt das sehe ich heute
auch noch so das schlimme ist wir haben
die impfpflicht ja längst also den
ganzen letzten wochen gab es zwei
restaurants die ungeimpften dürfen nicht
auf den weihnachtsmarkt
wenn kinder schlittschuh fahren darf die
mutter nicht mals dahin sich stellen und
dem kind zu schauen im freien die ist
längst da aber jetzt als noch weiter
gehen jetzt soll die richtige
impfpflicht her ich finde das falsch
[Musik]
du findest mich also schwierig weil ich
für die impfpflicht bin aber nina machen
wir uns nichts vor wären wir alle
geimpft müssen wir jetzt nicht wieder
angst vor einem flop daun haben ja ohne
die impfpflicht feld für uns alle
weiterhin ein stück leben aus
weihnachtsfeiern geburtstage abiparty
seminare all das ist nicht mehr möglich
wir stehen still weil eine minderheit
sich nicht bewegt das recht auf freiheit
ist ja nicht absolut deine freiheit
endet wenn sie anfängt meine
einzuschränken ich habe die reine zahlen
mitgebracht aus meiner heimatstadt
hamburg bei den ungeimpften liegt die
inzidenz dort bei 898 und bei den
geimpften personen nur bei 24
mit einer inzidenz von 24 werden wir
komplett frei also das was du dir
bestimmt auch wünscht
[Musik]
wir wollen das mit der freiheit das
argument finde ich persönlich ganz ganz
schwierig weil du argumentiert dass wir
alle frei sind wenn alle geimpft sind
aber erst mal nehmen wir menschen die
freiheit weg wenn der staat reingeht und
verordnet dass man geimpft werden muss
dann nimmt er dem bürger die freiheit
der freien entscheidung er sagt er
verordnet einen medizinischen eingriff
bei menschen wo er vorher versprochen
hat die impfpflicht kommt in keinem fall
ich bin genauso wie du der überzeugung
dass wir um die pandemie zurückzukämpfen
eine höhere impfquote brauchen also auch
die zahl aus seiner heimatstadt da
stimme ich natürlich zu ich habe mich
auch direkt am anfang impfen lassen ich
empfinde die ebenfalls großes geschenk
aber wir müssen mit argumenten ran und
nicht mit einer pflicht und nicht mit
zwang
[Musik]
die forderung nach einer impfpflicht das
ist ja das was den staat so ausmacht
dass er jetzt endlich mal gezeigt was er
kann ja das ist etwas worauf ich die
ganze zeit gewartet habe ein definitives
statement du musst das jetzt machen das
ist jetzt nicht mehr nur deine wahl und
warum ist das so er hat klare kante
gezeigt olaf scholz ja unsere regierung
zeigt endlich mal stärke du kannst du in
einer krise wie wir sie jetzt haben
nicht die ganze zeit rum bayern die
politik hat die ganze zeit rumgeeiert
und nichts wirklich entschieden und
jetzt sagt sie doch du musst das jetzt
machen und zwar der staat kann nicht
allen gerecht werden sondern er muss das
tun was für die allgemeinheit das beste
ist ja und die politiker sind davon
ausgegangen dass die menschen angesichts
der toten von alleine das richtige haben
sie aber nicht gemacht
[Applaus]
es ist also für dich politische stärke
vom eigenen versagen abzulenken und
einen sündenbock in der gesellschaft hin
zu stellen der sündenbock der
ungeimpften sind schuld er diesen
schultes ich meine freiheit nicht habe
das sehe ich komplett anders wie weit
wären wir wenn die regierung ihre
logistik im griff gehabt hätte wenn
damals sehr viel impfstoff da gewesen
wäre damals waren die zweifel nehme ich
noch gar nicht so groß in der
bevölkerung wie heute ich finde es ganz
schlimm wie olaf scholz sich hinstellt
und die ungeimpften dafür verantwortlich
macht und weiß was ich auch glaube wir
werden die impfquote nicht erhöhen mit
der pflicht vielleicht wenn wir die
leute wirklich zwangsimpfung aber
ansonsten wird die niemals höher die
menschen werden noch mehr in die ecke
gedrängt und sich noch weniger impfen
lassen wollen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist mir eigentlich egal ob sich
irgendwelche leute in die ecke gedrängt
fühlen ich möchte mich einfach nicht
mehr ärgern und ich ärgere mich immens
über in verweigerer ja die alten und
kranken keiner denkt an sie ich finde
das ist ein asoziales verhalten wenn man
nicht an die denkt meine schuld kind
muss stundenlang masken tragen und hat
jetzt bald wahrscheinlich auch kein
unterricht mehr weil wir wieder in
homeschooling gehen eine freundin von
mir kann ihren schwiegervater nicht mehr
im altenheim besuchen ein freund von mir
der hat ne bar der ist fast pleite meine
eltern können ihre goldene hochzeit
nicht feiern all das wegen im verweigern
weil sie uns nicht impfen lassen meine
tante die hat die führt ein krankenhaus
und auf der intensivstation
liegen fast nur ungeimpfte corona
patienten ja und die befürchtet jetzt
immense überstunden wieder von den
pflegern franken
wir wollen da sind wir genau auf einer
linie ich finde es ganz schlimm diese
beispiele von denen du es auch erzählt
ich habe auch viele meinem umfeld die
unter krone gelitten haben oder noch
leiden darunter was ja auch die
nebenwirkungen sind dadurch dass wir die
pandemie haben da gibt es ja auch
wirtschaftliche nebenwirkungen weil sich
über sagen muss ist du bist für die
impfpflicht aber was wird denn die
impfpflicht bringen ich muss den punkt
leider noch mal bringen sie sehen wir
meinen osten im osten in deutschland ist
die impfbereitschaft eigentlich viel
höher als im westen außer bykow wird die
regierung hat es nicht geschafft die
menschen zu überzeugen
die menschen haben angst vor der impfung
das müssen wir mit aufklärung machen und
nicht länger mit zwang es wird nicht
klappen und was passiert wenn einmal die
gesellschaft etwas von dir oder deinen
kindern verlangt was du nicht bereit bis
zu geben muss man da nicht auch
solidarisch sein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nena ich find's gut dass du die kinder
erwähnst du weißt dass ich kinder habe
und mir geht es bei dieser impfpflicht
auch um die psychische gesundheit nicht
nur der kinder von uns allen warum weil
wir endlich wieder planen müssen wir
schauen jetzt überhaupt nie in die
zukunft die zukunft ist für uns ein
synonym für angst und für bedrohung und
ich glaube dass uns das auf dauer nicht
gut tut ja wir waren meiner ansicht nach
seit der wende nie so unfrei wie jetzt
wenn ich das wort kontakt beschränkung
schon höre dann bekomme ich beklemmungen
ja und ich möchte dass wir einfach
wieder normal leben und warum ist das in
diesem winter noch schlimmer als im
letzten winter weil wir jetzt eine
chance hätten eigentlich etwas mit dem
impfstoff gegen diese beklemmung und
gegen unsere unfreiheit zu tun
[Musik]
und dass nena und yvonne war euer duell
neuer streitgespräch um die impfpflicht
euch vielen dank all das ist bild einmal
kraft dagegen gegen die impfpflicht
einmal total dafür und entschieden wird
neuer streit im bundestag